my guest tonight is a comedian who stars
in the digital series cop show
his new book right here overstated
a coast-to-coast roast of the 50 states
is available now i have read this book
and it is fantastic
please welcome mr colin quinn
colin thanks conan how are you oh yeah
you know
let's talk okay well i'd like to start
by saying i don't like that guitar for
you
because it's a little bit uh it's a
little bit flashy you know what i mean
i see you more with like a kind of a you
know a van morris an acoustic thing you
know yeah yeah
yeah no no why is it there let me tell
you something it's not even my guitar
and this is the thing about you colin
you are very perceptive
deceptively so this is not my guitar
uh the guy that sets up our stage just
said it there it's his guitar i don't
own a red guitar
i don't have a flashy guitar no there
you go course not
no honestly even an electric guitar is a
little bit of a you know
indulgence that irish people should not
be involved in you don't think the irish
deserve to play an electric guitar
i just don't you think we're you think
we sell
so self-hating and self-loathing
that the only thing we can do is play a
guitar that hasn't been electrified
yeah yeah like oh look at this thinks
he's pretty good for himself he's
plugged in his guitar
oh look at him he thinks he's a tall
puppy plugging in the guitar
oh mr fancy pants speaking of guitars
and irish people
you have to admit they put bono bono
was the king of the world and irish
people
put him back where he shut he he shut
down
do you think they shut him down they
they
they totally did yeah but like because
he was getting so cocky wearing glasses
getting a little flashy
dressing flashy and now he's back to
like listen i'm just here to play
and i'm going to start trouble right
irish arrest
here's what the yes exactly the irish
don't like it if one of their own makes
it
in any way that's why i've been very
careful in my career
to have some success but not too much
yeah well look who you're talking i'm in
the same way and you got to
deprecate yourself and you're fine
that's all that matters yeah wouldn't
you tell me that thing about
the irish that's the whole thing about
boston when i go back to boston they're
like oh
think you're a big guy huh you're like i
just i just ordered a latte that's all i
did
i didn't cause any trouble i'm just
eating a hot dog i didn't i didn't say
anything
i used to do a routine in boston only i
do it where i talk about how every other
city
they go you know st louis like john
hamm's from here
and so and so so-and-so is from here i
go you go to boss you go hey ben
affleck's from here they got
him my friend
my friend bumped into him at foxborough
mall he didn't do nothing so
[Laughter]
that is so true about boston i was i was
in boston a couple of years ago and i
went to use the men's room staying in a
hotel
i go to use the men's room which is off
the bar and this
i want to say an older woman with a
really thick
accent comes into the men's room and
goes conan
come on in and i went excuse me it's a
men's room at the euro and she went oh
mr big shot you're like what are you
talking about
it's called i made a urinal with my dick
out
[Laughter]
oh the high and mighty hollywood where
old ladies aren't allowed to come into a
men's room and talk to you while you're
peeing it's insanity
now i talked to you recently on the
podcast uh
i have a little side gig conor bryan
needs a friend
people love your episode you were
hilarious and that's when i said i got
to talk to this man some more i'll get
him on the tv show
but um we got into it a little bit you
got upset with me
because you said that i um
i smeared the image of one of your
favorite irish poets
you're not only from not only for the
public but it also ruined it for me
which is what really hurts
which is yates william butler yates
basically a saint of ireland
you know what i mean great poet one of
the great probably the greatest irish
poet
and this mystic figure you know that you
always think is above
worldly concerns and then you point out
that he was like
getting some kind of like old-timey
erectile dysfunction uh techniques it's
true yeah that's true
i pointed out to you all i did was give
you a little history lesson and i said
that yates
later in life uh was concerned about
his ability to perform in the bedroom so
at the time in the 1930s there was a
quack doctor who was saying i'll inject
you
with monkey glands the glands that have
ground up monkey glands into your
testicles
and it will help you it was the viagra
of its day only it didn't work
it was even worse because the way it
started was me going
one thing about the irish and yates they
aged gracefully
like we don't mind getting old and then
you brought that up and it just
shattered my
illusions about yates well you know i
could make it up to you by
reciting some yates for you maybe
that'll do it you know
maybe you'd like that would you like
that joy would i will arise and go now
and go to innisfree and a log cabin
build there of clay and wattles made
nine bean rows will i plant there
and a hive for the honeybee
i like that that's a guy who's high on
monkey glands
that is a guy who was this rejoice he
was
so jacked up on uh ape glands
injected into his testicles that he
wrote that poem and that's probably how
he recited it
probably how he did recite it you're
right and he was completely iraq the
entire time
oh hmm sorry hope sorry to ruin all the
poets for you
well i'll next time i'll tell you what
joyce was injected with
let's talk about more earthly matters
shall we colin
don't mind i was very concerned to hear
that you got
covid in november and i'm glad to see
you looking well tell us about that
experience
right after we did the podcast it
couldn't have been a few days later
don't point at me i didn't give it to
you no you did not give it to me
and um i got caught i did another
podcast
chris distefano giannis pappas so they
had done something between that you know
i like to
i like to name my you know i don't want
to hide behind
and so i went home and they said i
started feeling terrible
next you know i was struck with covet
and what does it feel like stricken
it feels like what everybody says you
can't smell
you can't taste and then um
you just feel horrible but luckily for
me i had a heart attack two years before
so i was eligible to get the infusion
who says
you know i've never heard someone say
luckily i had a heart attack two years
ago
no one says that colin except you but
that put you on a special list that
meant you got the infusion of the
antibodies right
yes i had the antibodies infusion so you
know
and it was uh so that really did work i
have to say
a few days later i was better but here's
the problem
i gave it to my wife
so even though i was feeling better she
wasn't eligible for the infusion
she was feeling terrible so
not only did i have to not only to
change the power dynamic of the whole
relationship of course
but i had to walk around and act like i
wasn't that much better
you know what i would have done cohen i
would have walked around the house and
said you know what feels good
those antibodies
those feel good what do you think
do you think this is good because
there's a trend in comedy that's been
around for a long time where if you
experience a difficulty
they say it's good for comedy because
then you can talk about it in your act
is having kovid and you survived it and
you're well now is that gonna be good
for your comedy in any way
yeah i think i can use it the way like
if somebody's uh
tries to medically appropriate and talk
about covent
i'm going to be like you really
shouldn't talk about it unless you're a
covet survivor
like myself so yeah it's medical
appropriation
but what i'm going to do is i'll
probably i'll do my acting like 20
minutes in
i'll do a couple of covert jokes
everyone's laughing and i'll be like
this
i um i had covered
last november and then just take
you know what i mean that's part of the
show room gets really quiet yeah
right and i go and it's inter and this
way you do like two minutes of intro
before you get to another joke
it's interesting because people what
they say about covert it's
and then just go into like some
nonsensical rant
that saves me two minutes of joke
writing and then you're a joke
and everyone's like oh obliged to laugh
he had covert you were probably thinking
about all of this
as you were coming down with kovid you
were thinking i see how i'm gonna use
this
i see how i'm gonna use this in my
comedy act all i was thinking of
was the the the revenge i would get upon
the people that gave it to me
you know who gave it to you yes
i told you i was on a podcast you know
you never finished your sentence
colin you finish one of every nine
sentences what you said is
uh i'll tell you who i was on a well i
was on a
well you see how it goes no you never
told us i know
you know it's funny i know
i know no because i was talking about
with stand-up comedy
it's really been the bane of my
existence my material is
you know great my delivery has been
very uh like very
jarring for people and i've never really
i never realized it my whole career you
know
so easily even when you were a young
comic starting out
you you and doing stand-up you had this
pattern
this focal pattern of maybe starting a
sentence but maybe not completely
finishing it
yes and i would finish it like a
throwaway
so because i was doing that if
i i've only realized this recently
because for years people would critique
it
and i'd be like come on but i realized i
made the audience
work as much as i worked on stage
people come out for a nice relaxing
night of comedy
and they're gonna sit back oh no they're
gonna sit back
have a few drinks and listen to a show
no
i made them have to go through the
torture that i have to go through
of thinking changing lanes in the middle
and i guess for a lot of people
that's not their idea of a good time
that's not entertainment
you you like to make your audience write
the second part of the joke for you
that's what you like
well i like to make them think that
they're into what i'm thinking
when i get to it they're like yes we're
on the same page
got it um you uh
you say you've claimed because i i'm
a big fan of yours and i listen to you
talk a lot and
you have claimed that you think you
believe because you're very successful
comedian you're very well known
you think you've bombed more than any
other successful comedian
do you think that's true oh absolutely
it's true
i would say in my first few years i
bombed so i was
my first years i bombed probably fifty
percent of the time and what was that
what tell give me an example
paint the picture of me colin the worst
experience the worst
uh bomb that you experienced as a comic
in a club in the early years in the
early years
one of the worst at least was i was in
uh north tonawanda which is north of
buffalo
and the setup was a movie theater
and then we're gonna see one comic then
made and then watch
ferris bueller's day off so it was like
1986.
so the whole town is there you know and
the first guy goes up he has a musical
thing to his act so he's like playing
music and it's great in his giant
theater
so music changes the energy i mean he
killed
so hard that i was like this is and i
was new to comedy i was only doing it
for about
a year and a half maybe i was like this
this is really i hope i can do well
i go out there do a couple of jokes and
they just
i changed the energy nobody wanted to
hear this rambling after this fun music
they turn on me so hard i turn on them i
start giving them the finger while i'm
doing my act
the violent i had to leave out the side
entrance
the owner of the theater is going like
this to me in the middle people
boom boom going yeah right but
he sneaks me into his car i'm looking up
as we're driving
quietly down the street because
everybody left the theater there's guys
with bats
like kids with bats
[Laughter]
the audience was so mad they got bats
and went looking for you
that's right yeah and then there was a
letter in the paper
like a few days later about the terrible
you know
comedian like they wrote a letter i wish
i had that newspaper in the local paper
other people saved their clippings for
different reasons
the best part was the booker
didn't pay me i call him up screaming
you son of a bit you know i probably
cost him the gig
i was angrier than he was that's good
you stood i would have crumpled in
shame you went the other way you called
him up and yelled at him and said you
owe me my money
yeah i don't think he would have paid me
you know the one of the it's hard to
explain to young people today but in the
late 1980s
there was no bigger deal
for a stand-up comic than to be offered
a slot
on johnny carson's tonight show it was
it overnight changed careers you were
doing well enough
that the booker for the tonight show saw
you and said
johnny's going to love this guy and
offered you a slot on the tonight show
to which you said i said
no thank you
[Laughter]
people were killing for that what what
were you thinking
i mean you know this i have a lot of uh
delusions of grandeur
but one of the things i was thinking was
like i'm not changing my act
to go on the third show because remember
even though people loved it
there was something i grew up watching
prior and carlin
so even though they went on the tonight
show they kind of looked down on us
so i didn't notice that i wasn't prior
or calling
right and so i figured he told me you
just can't
you know you can't curse on that go
forget it then
[Laughter]
so they said just colin you can come on
the show it's going to change your life
overnight you'll be one of the biggest
comics in america
at such a young age all we ask is that
you don't
curse and you refused yeah i said
nah that's all right then you know i
don't need to you know what i mean like
i didn't need that wasn't going to be on
my me my medium was not going to be
there
help me with this when the booker for
the tonight show who's never
heard anybody turn them down had you on
the phone
what is this what's this in person
it was in person you were talking to the
book of the tonight show in person
at the improv in l.a yeah and they come
up to you and they say okay colin we
think you're ready and you say
no what did they say he started laughing
he couldn't believe it he couldn't
believe it you started laughing
he goes what what
he was just laughing at me
you uh you know you like to there's a
confrontational
heir to your personality which i've
always
loved you like things to be difficult
you like to get into it with people you
don't want it to be a smooth ride
and i sympathize because i i think there
is something of an irish quality where
we we expect it to be difficult we want
it to be difficult and we're
uncomfortable if it's easy
for a long time you were going on
twitter and you were just
trying to irritate people and start
fights isn't that true
well i mean i'm still try but everybody
knows my game
but yeah when i started out i i just
noticed i put some ironic tweet out
there like you know
to me the best uh the best beatles song
is i got my mind set on you
it's not even a beatles song it's a
george harrison solo song
from the 80s a lot of people a lot of
people pointed that out too
well for a while i was just doing music
trolls where i was like
you know i like real punk you know like
i'm i'm not into this new punk i'm into
like real punk like
ramones and avril lavigne
and people would get so mad you it was
just kind of that kind of thing you know
yeah yeah you even get you get mad at
people
uh if someone says they don't like the
beatles that pisses you off
well that bugs me i mean talk about
trolling
everybody that doesn't like the beatles
they're just
dying for you to go what they think
they're going to blow your mind
that's what bugs me they're not if they
don't not like the beatles they just
want to blow your mind with their you
know iconoclastic
person the best thing to do if somebody
says they don't like the beatles is go
okay
then that'll ruin their whole day
they won't be like what
so okay yeah i get it i get it yeah
let's talk about uh cop show cop show
i've been looking at these uh
these digital clips cop show and really
it's really funny
it's really funny and you and what's
what i love about it
is that it's this digital series where
you
look like a guy who should be in a new
york cop show you know what i mean you
you look like
you you look like a guy who should be
there with the cup of coffee
making those sort of jerry orbach smart
alec comments and this is
a great take off of that genre
and i think it works because you are
that guy you are the guy that should be
in that show and
it so to me that's why it works well we
have a clip here
which will give everyone a very nice
taste of what cop show
is all about let's take a look at that
right now
yeah what have we got female caucasian
late 20s looks to be possibly deceased
looks like a real nice girl
apparently somebody didn't think so cut
cut does that last line sound too mean
let's maybe
just uh do take where we lose the the
kick
kick the corpse i don't feel like our
cop would do that right
on the next take i think we should show
the horror of murder
by getting a close-up on the eyes yeah
yeah i like that i like that a lot okay
guys so we're gonna go
uh tight in on the victim's eye no not
the victim's eyes
close up on my eyes
oh yeah i'm sure if you if you want that
we can do that uh guys
the horror of murder yeah
do you look like you're having a lot of
fun making that
i have so much fun i could do that for
10 years if i could
if i had the money i mean i love it um
well let me get the word out on
on cop show all episodes of collins
digital series cup show
are now available to stream on his
youtube channel
huh yeah it's the only thing on my
youtube channel it's very easy to find
well don't say that make it sound like
it's a big going concern
there's a lot going on with your youtube
channel and if you're lucky you'll catch
this
learn how to play the game a little bit
you don't go that's all there is
that's all i got that's it
it's i like i like the equally ongoing
concern
it's a going concern it's a going
concern
also uh i said this to you before but
you know there's a lot of comedians out
there that they crank out comedy books
and i got to tell you i look at them and
i can tell they did this in about 10
minutes
you're a great you're a great writer
you're a terrific writer
and um and you have this is a very
well thought out book of very funny
essays about
all the states in the united states so
uh check it out
uh colin's new book overstated a
coast-to-coast roast of the 50 states is
available
right now and maybe if they turn it on
the youtube channel there'll be a plug
for it
well yeah it's on the uh i'm putting the
book on the youtube channel
see because it's a going concern you
want people you want people to tune in
colin i'll switch the guitar i'll get
rid of the guitar you're
right it's not mine it doesn't match my
personality
yeah you should have a you you should
have a bedazzled guitar
blue what no i'm kidding no i'm joking
i'll get a
you know i'm here at the largo theater
do you know the largo theater here in
los angeles
yeah i did shows there many years ago
yeah yeah you know flanny the guy that
runs it he's from belfast
no you'd like him he told him to get you
a
telling me i said van maar is a guitar
he probably has one he i think he lives
with van morrison
it's ridiculous they they're they're
they live in bunk beds
fan is on the top and flanny's on the
bottom so uh
yeah that's the kind of guitar i need i
need that kind of guitar you're right
yes yes you know colin without you i'd
be lost
thank you very much you're a good man
thank you and i know that
uh i guess i'm kind of a hero to you i
guess i'm just gonna say that
yes and we can add that later on in your
own voice all right
colin god bless you too bye conan thanks